بسم الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله الحم الحد
الحدد
ومنه ال
الله مح
عرسه وادى الامانه ونح الا وشف تعالى ود
في الله حق جها حتى اتاه اليقين اما
بعد فقال الله سبحانه وتعالى في القران
المجيد وفرقان حمد بعد اقول اعوذ بالله من
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يا
ايها الذين امن اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا
تموتن الا وانم مسلمون ثم اما بعد ان اصدق
الكتاب كتاب الله تعالى وخير هدي هدي محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم وشر امور محدثها
محدثه بعه وكل بعه ضاله و ضاله في النار
رحي صدر ويسي ام واح عقده من لساني يفقه
قولي اللهم لا سحل الا ما جعلته سحلا وانت
تجعل الحزن اذا شئت سحلا ولا حول ولا قوه
الا بالله العلي العظيم الله ربنا وقتنا
ورجاؤنا ومولانا فنعم المولى
[Silence]
محمدصلى الله عليه وسمانه
‏there
take the sun hardly rises and seems like
is a and the
newly and seem a mon is a day
‏yearly quickly
life
ed صلى الله عليه وسلم حديث ترم لا تقوم
ساعه حتى يتقارب الذمان فتكون سنه كهر
وشهر
كجمعه جمعه كيوم
اليوم اليوم كساعه وتكون ساعه ضرمه النار
او كما قال عليه الصلاه
[Silence]
والسلام life
ا لناس حسابهم وهم غفله معون
الله
سبحان شق
القمر القمر
اللهبه وما يدرك سعه
قريب
الشعراء
make وما امر عه
الا البصر وهو ا وهو اقرب ان الله على كل
شيء قدير الله وتاله
النحل all
things رسول الله
صلس بعث بعث انا وساعد هكذا ويشير ب
باصابعه فيمد
بهما عليه الصلا والسلام
حث عليه اللام
[Silence]
اللهه مثل الحياه الدنيا كماء ان انزلناه
من السماء فاخترت به نبات الارض مما ياكل
الناس والانعام حتى اخطت
الارض الله سبحان
‏life
from
earth and
eat earth
takes
and
over
andes and and weest as not fl
كذل نفص الاات لقوم
رر grow and grow
there back
‏some life
[Silence]
‏life
any when down
ames
green liv however
[Silence]
‏because
life
love all
‏and
life
was green
landen
andell
andy
sar
behold bey
اللهبه حدي وما الحياه الن الا
م
life nature life
[Silence]
قلوا عن انفسكم الموت كنتم
صادقين النساء
كم الموت ولو كنتم فيرو
مشيده القب كل نفس زقه الموت ثم
العه قل ان المت الذين تون منه فانه
الله
سانتال
earth
life hours الله سبحانه
وتالى سه المؤم
سه المؤمنون قلكم كم لبثتم في العرض عدد
السنين قالوا لبثنا يوما او بعض يسال الع
الله
people us
عن سوره النازعات كانهم يوما يرونها لم
يلبثوا الا
عشيا او
ضحاها
as رسول الله صل علسلم
حديث عليه الصلا والسلام
صحي
مسلم ما الدنيا في الاخره الا مثل ما يجعل
احدكم اصابعه في هذ اليم فلينظر بما
ترجع الله
[Silence]
‏that from that glass of and what is
compon glass of water to thea of the
earth حسن ال
الله
feet life
‏take he
from
ex
frequently
life
love
theirs take
[Silence]
قد ا
منقد
من ‏we ask allah سح wal to make us from
the people who listens to the words of
quran and gets inspired and we ask allah
taal to make us from the people who do
not get lost in the he of this world and
that he does not take us from this world
until allah him himself is happy and
satisfied with us as a believer and when
he does take us from this world the
words roll out of لا اله الله مد
ث الله ى الله
عليهم تمع واستغفر الله لي ولكم وسائل
المسلمين ذمب فاستغفر غف الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد
لله الحمد لله واحدد الفر الذ لم يلد وم
يد وم يك لف احد
‏days
[Silence]
‏are mon and
only quickly let us take he from
those and
make
not
make mon
of of the engaging rem anding
[Silence]
مفر واج عظيمه
‏and
from ex gra andw cler
among on
of as
ex ولتكملوا العده ولا تكبروا الله على ما
حداكم لعلكم ولعلكم تشكرون
[Silence]
الله اكب الله اكبر لا اله الله الله اكب
اكبر الحمد الله الله
[Silence]
الله
شال حث منم رمضان ايم واحتسابا وتبع من
شوال فان فانه كانه صائم
الهر
رمضان
days ع الله سبهالى
[Silence]
‏foring and
sister was
aare as
[Silence]
الله
سحال
ح الله
سبهالى
ع ح
‏bey do
not are worship all
all حى يقينى يقين
[Silence]
الله سبحان
ان الله ولائه يصلون على النبي يا ا الذين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلم
تسليما صل الله عليه
وسلم اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافينا في
عافيت وتولنا في توليت وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت وكنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت
انك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يزل من
واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
تعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر
لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم
تغفر لنا وترحمنا لكن من الخاسرين اللهم
انك عفو كريم تحب العفو فاعفو عنا اللهم
انك عفو كريم تحب العف فاعفو عنا اللهم
انك عفو كريم تحب العف فاعف عنا اللهم
انسر الاسلام والمسلمين اللهم انسر دينك
وكتابك اللهم ان نبيك محمد وسنه نبيك محمد
وعبادك الصالحين اللهم ازز الشرك
والمشركين ودمر اعداء الدين يا قوي يا
عزيز اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار ورقاب
والدينا وذريتنا وازواجنا وارحام
وامهاتنا وابائنا و مشايخنا واصحابنا
وادخلنا جنه مع الابرار يا عزيز يا غفار
اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق الفو و كاام
بعد الموت اغفري جميع مت المسلمين الذين
شاهدك بالوحدانيه ونبيك بالرساله وماتوا
على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم وارحمهم وعافه
وعفو عنهم واكرم نزلهم ووسع مدخلهم
واقتلهم بالماء الثلج والبرد ونقهم من
الذنوب والخطايا كما الثوب الابيض من
الدنس ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما حيتنا واجعله وارث منا
واجعل ثرنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عاد
ولا تسط علينا بذنوبنا من لا يخافك فينا
ولا يرحمنا اللهم عز جارك وجل ثناءك وتقدس
اسماك اللهم لا يرد امرك ولا يحزن جندك
سبحانك وبحمدك اللهم اعد المسجد الاقصى
الى رحاب المسلمين اللهم اعد المسجد
الاقصى الى رحاب المسلمين اللهم ا المسجد
الاقصى الى رحاب المسلمين وارزقنا فيه
صلاه القبل الممات اللهم انصر الاسلام
اللهم انصر اخوان المستضعفين في فلسطين
وغزه وفي السودان وفي السين وفي برما وفي
كشمير وفي هند وفي كل مكان اللهم ايده جنك
لا يعلم جنك الا انت يا قوي يا عزيز اللهم
نسالك خي من كل عاجله واجله وما علمنا منه
ولا لم نعلم ونعوذ بك من شر كل عاجله
واجله وما علمنا منه ولا لم نعلم اللهم
نسالك خير وما سالك عبدك ونبيك ونعوذ بك
من شر ماعا بك عبدك ونبيك اللك النه اللهم
نسالك الجنه اللهم نسالك الجنه وما قرب
اليه من قول وعمل ونعوذ بك من النار ونعوذ
بك من النار ونعوذ بك من النار وما قرب
اليه من قول
وعمل نسالك ان تجعل كل قضاء قضيه لنا خير
يا رب العالمين عباد الله ان الله يامر ان
الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان وذ القربى وحى
فحشاء منكر بغي يعيذ لعلكم تذكرون اذكروا
الله العظيم يذكركم واشكر ذكر لكم وذكر
الله اك وقوم الى صلاتكم يرحمكم
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله
الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدلوا
استو الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين بسم
الله ان للمتقين
مفازا
حدائق
واعنابا وكواعب اترابا
وكاسا
دهاقا لا يسمعون فيها لغوا ولا
كذابا
جزاء من ربك
عطاء
حسابا رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما
الرحمن الرحمن لا يملكون منه خطاب
يوم يقوم الروح
والملائكه صفا لا
يتكلمون لا
يتكلمون الا من اذن له الرحمن وقال
صوابا ذلك اليوم
الحق فمن
شاء اتخذ الى ربه ماب
انا
انذرناكم
عذابا
قريبا يوم
ينظر المرء ما قدمت
يدا ويقول الكافر يا ليتني
كنت
ترابا الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا صراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين اذا جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفره
انه كان
توابا الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏re
‏u
pay landscaping and all
stun the aff of that cy and all that is
being donated by you brother and sisters
it doesn't come from other source
because we don't have life trust so
brother and sister back here again
asking you to help us out for this the
expenses which are raman
expenses da ac ‏the u
and there is runing the s scho that is
also covered with so anyway without any
delay i would to ask somebody would
to the hand for 000